I saw that Roger Federer was one of he's
part of the uh the Billy athlete Club so
there's like Federer is
five athletes who have made a billion
dollars Tiger Woods
Floyd Mayweather
LeBron James
Ronaldo and I think Michael Jordan may
be messy so that might be six I think
it's five
um and now Federer is in that club
[Music]
the whole Adam Levine thing's ridiculous
it's just like is that in like the
Santa's fake section of the newspaper as
well it's just like the most obvious
like people are like acting like it's
like a big deal it's like dude what do
you expect look at the guy of course he
cheats
I don't even know the story why did he
cheat
oh no because why like what's the
controversy like did he do something
really crazy I I only read the headlines
I think he just texted like texted her
Instagram like his yoga trainer and said
I want to roll around naked with you all
day and then he texted this other lady
that says like
um you know like he like said like hey
like I want to go out with you like why
are you so hot or something like that
and then later on weeks later he texts
and says hey my wife's pregnant and
we're gonna name the baby your name is
that cool with you which is super
freaking weird but uh I don't know if he
did anything wrong like legally but he's
just you know just doing what like guys
with like body tatts who live in L.A do
you know you just cheat
laughs
like you could he's got the face of a
cheater right I mean this is obvious at
the bottom of your tattoo sleeve is just
a place to put your number
I wouldn't have got this sleeve as a
married man if I wasn't trying to you
know play the game dude speaking of bros
I think I've just invented something
I've been doing this for the past few
weeks I call it uh like Fitness dip so
you know how like you know people dip
like tobacco they put like uh stuff in
their lip lately uh yeah you know like
chewing tobacco you put it in your lips
I've heard of it but you're the only guy
I know who does it yeah just like a fat
lip lately what I've been doing is just
put in have you seen PB fit it's like
powdered peanut butter yeah that stuff's
great I love it dude I just get a like a
tablespoon of it and I just stick it on
the roof of my mouth and I'll just suck
on it for like an hour and I just it's
my fitness dip and it just keeps me like
from like pacifier for you yeah it keeps
you it's like chewing gum almost like
you know you can't eat anything because
you got that in the roof of your mouth
and you're just sucking on it real
slowly that's my new fit in this dip all
right so how do you get an idea like
this like I'm not saying it's I'm not
saying it's probably doesn't taste good
or it might be therapeutic or whatever
but why are you like you know what
something need to I need something on
the top of my mouth what can I do what
can I do what can I do a pbfit powder
all right I'm gonna like I've never even
wanted to put anything at the top of my
mouth
nor have I just taken foods and be like
what if I stuck this here for an hour
would that be better than just eating it
because I go to the store and I just
like look at all the products like
looking at new stuff and it says to add
water and I'm like what if I don't what
if I just eat this as plain powder and I
Do Without a Cause over here
I don't know I just tried it it was
interesting to me it it just Add Water
don't tell me what to do
it works it works you should try it
I definitely will not uh all right so
what do we got today you got ideas I've
got topics I've got a ton of stuff let
me uh we can start off with something
one thing that's like I don't know if
this is actually interesting or not you
tell me but basically I'm reading this
book called more money than God and it's
about the history of hedge funds you
know anything about hedge funds not not
a lot tell me yeah well you know I'm
only in the first half of the book so I
can't tell you much about how they
operate now but because you know we're
still in like the 1980s but basically
the guy who invented it was called a
hedged fund and his name was Alfred
Jones Alfred Winslow Jones A.W Jones is
what they call them and it's kind of
interesting he was a journalist for
Fortune you know he was just a writer
it's crazy that fortune even existed
back then this was in like the 30s and
40s and for some reason for some reason
hedged fund is so funny to me that's
what it that's what it was called I know
it's I know it's real but for some
reason it just seems like something we
would just say wrong trying to be smart
be like yeah I'm looking at investing in
some head yeah and people be like is he
putting a D in here
like you know go out there have fun and
break an egg you know
[Laughter]
so it's called it was called a hedged
fun and he was researching for an
article stock Pickers and he found this
like small group of people that were
doing like some slightly different stuff
with hedge funds or with stock picking
and at the time like basically rich
people viewed Wall Street and a lot of
like Equity investing as just a way to
preserve wealth not really grow wealth
and this guy A.W Jones he was in his 40s
journalist and he goes oh with these you
know small group of people that I'm
researching this like mathematical
formula stuff that they're doing it's
actually really really interesting and
so
P raises I think a hundred thousand
dollars at the time and what he does is
basically uh the kind of dumb way of
explaining it is which is the only way I
understand it uh is that he just like
does a combination of longing going long
on things with borrowing leverage
meaning if he invests eighty thousand
dollars he would borrow another fifty
thousand dollars now he's a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars into a stock
then with the rest of his hundred
thousand dollars he would buy shorts in
such a combination where his upside was
much higher and his downside was a
little bit protected and there was like
some math behind it and at the time this
was revolutionary but here's where
things get actually really cool that
itself wasn't the Revolutionary part I
mean that was one part of it but what's
the main thing the really cool thing
that he did which wasn't done ever
before is he hired these young stock
Pickers and instead of just giving them
a salary he goes all right you work for
me I've raised a million dollars you get
fifty thousand you get fifty thousand
you get fifty thousand you get fifty
thousand you can go and hire two people
to work with you you're your own group
you're your own group you're your own
group and uh get after it let's see what
you can do uh the person who does the
least best or the person does worst you
guys are out and he created this like
Cutthroat culture of these people who
were just getting after it and he was
the first person that made it so you
they were only paid a percentage so 20
of future upside and at the time he did
it because that was that just means your
your tax more uh uh it was more
beneficial for you it wasn't income tax
it was a capital gains tax and your tax
benefits were like way greater but he
told his folks he goes yes the reason
we're doing this is Phoenician sea
captains used to keep a fifth of the
profits of successful voyages and that's
like how he like he didn't say hey it's
uh just so we can for this tax thing but
like he like Justified there's a weird
reason but anyway this team structure
that's what like changed everything
prior to that Wall Street was just like
the stodgy sleepy place of like look
we're just doing 80 stocks 20 bonds and
we just let it sit there but then once
he changed that incentive structure
everything changed and that kind of got
me interested that's kind of like been
sitting with me because at the hustle we
used to do this too where uh for our
quotas for our sales people we would say
you know go out and get ad sales and you
get a percentage of what you close but
then they would close like dumb [__]
they would close like for example
they're like who cares if it's a porn
company if it's a weed company if it's a
shitty service like it doesn't matter
and then we're like well actually that's
a good point we need like inverse
incentives like uh you know do the
readers like this is a click-through
rate high do they renew and I couldn't
figure out how to do that successfully I
couldn't figure out because both I
thought I thought for sure the story was
ending with so then I created a better
system and it worked beautifully you're
like I I couldn't figure that [__] out
that's too coffee
I thought so I would have bet anything
that you were about to say so then we
did this and pat on the back I did a
great job because I'm so used to people
doing that like you know in Tech nobody
says you know we kind of hit this
problem
and we didn't solve it it just didn't
solve it you know that nobody ever tells
a story like that I love that you just
told a story like that that's amazing
well I I so with my new business I am
trying to think I'm like how do I solve
this you know like can I pay like 50 of
the but there's like but I started
researching different ways to solve this
and uh I don't know have you I'll tell
you a few other examples but have you
had with like the milk Road or with
anything that you've done have you had
where you're like if I just change the
incentives this other thing changed so
it's like the product isn't the
Revolutionary or interesting thing it's
like how you operate that's what's
interesting
yeah
um I don't think I have a great story
personally off the top of my head uh
like we just did one where we needed to
fill all the ads for like October or
something like that or like whatever
some future month and we were a little
light and it was like oh how do we get
this up
and um and Ben was just like you know if
we just told our like you know
salesperson we'll give him an extra 10K
if they can get this to if they can get
us you know to this fill rate
um I think they'll do it and and I was
like yeah but like that's the same thing
as their quota like if they just filled
it they would get that percentage he's
like no I think if we just say I'll give
you ten thousand dollars on top of your
quota if you could do this and I was
like okay I guess that makes sense and
uh instantly they like way overfilled it
so and I was like okay I don't think you
could do that all the time uh because
like you know this got them you know to
get off their ass and do something but
uh but yeah I thought that was
interesting so what's funny is you're
right that does work and you can do it
all the time so I was researching like
incentives and one of the there's a
handful of ways to make basically I
think Charlie Munger or some one of the
like Rich smart guys said like you show
me the incentives I'm gonna show you
future results or something like that
and show me your incentives and I'll
show you your outcomes and there are a
few successful ways to like incentivize
people and so one of those ways I was
reading this McKenzie study where they
said you actually should give bonuses
based on 105 performance not just 90
performance and research shows that if
you over attain to in order to get a
bonus people tend to do that versus the
other way around another thing is you do
um
clawbacks so you get 50 of a bonus up
front and if you don't achieve the goal
that you said you're going to get done
then I'm going to do what's called the
clawback and I'm going to take that
money from you so you can do this with
kids where you say hey look your
allowance is 100 a week or a hundred
dollars a month I'm actually going to
give you 50 now and the other 50 when
you do your chores but if you don't do
your chores you're giving me that 50
back and that lossed version is actually
uh performs better than if I just say
I'm going to give you a hundred dollars
at the end of the month if you do x y
and z
uh that's that's 100 right
um yeah the I think lost version is what
they what they call it but basically it
feels it feels worse to lose money you
have than to not gain the same amount of
money yeah it should be the same thing
but it's it's definitely not the same
thing and uh I had this when we did I
did a deal once where we got a million
dollar signing bonus but it was
contingent that if we if we left before
a year
um then we wouldn't get the million
dollars and uh I would uh personally I
wouldn't get the million dollars if uh
if I left before you and um and I think
if you had just told me hey do you want
to stay for a year to get this million
dollars I would be like well you know
that sounds good but there's other
opportunities maybe I could do it this
other way but once they just put the
money in my account they're like
that's there now go look at that okay
cool if you leave early you have to pay
all that back and I was like oh man I
gotta pay back a million dollars and it
just felt if my brain knew exactly what
was going on I was like I just don't
want to pay back a million dollars that
sounds like uh that would be horrible
I'm definitely not doing that I'm not
losing a million whereas if they had
just said hey if you if you stay a
little longer you can get this extra bit
I would have been like ah maybe I can go
get that some other way and um and
that's a kind of a crazy like psycho
like you know psychological trick I knew
what was going on and it still felt real
to me well and another interesting
example then we could move on but
another interesting example that I was
thinking about was for uh you know
what's like a really [__] up industry
is private prisons because you're
incentivized by like how many beds you
fill you know and that's like you know
doesn't align with what we want as a
society I'm like well what it should be
is you're paid a little bit of money for
how many beds you fill but then if the
inmate you know has a receipt if they go
back to prison inside the next four
years outside of being released you got
to give me that money back and if they
stay out I'll give you the second half
of your payment and I was just like I
was thinking of all these different ways
that uh because I was thinking about my
business I'm like how can I
change my incentives around in order to
get a different outcome and that was
like a really good example uh but it
seems the problem with incentives is
that a it's like to change them
you have to be kind of bold and like
kind of be the first to like really try
something new and B oftentimes it's not
always straightforward like did you
achieve this or like tracking the
results is actually like a huge task in
itself which is what we had at the
hustle I'm like I could do this but like
I gotta build all this stuff to like
track all this but anyway I yeah because
it's uh they call second order effects
basically usually the first thing you're
trying to incentivize does happen it's
the second thing that goes wrong
basically it's uh yeah you got your ads
filled but they filled it with certain
types of content which led to readers
being upset which led to churn or
whatever like you have to predict what
would be the uh the second order effect
that comes from some of this stuff
there's a there's like a Farnham Street
blog that I've read about this one but
the Cobra thing yeah like the Cobra
thing yeah go ahead sort of like
incentives gone wrong I don't remember
the story at this point but basically it
was like in India right now like there's
you know the stereotype of like a guy
playing like a porn or I don't know what
it's called and like the Cobra coming up
and like dancing and it was like well
why there's so many Cobras in India and
apparently I don't remember what year it
was but there there was a little bit of
a cobra problem and they go hey everyone
we're gonna give you 50 for every dead
Cobra you bring it bring to us thinking
great we're gonna have no more cobras
and but in reality uh the schemers were
like oh let's breed cobras and kill them
and bring them to you so like oh nice
it's free money this is awesome and that
there was now an overpopulation problem
of cobras I I actually have no idea if
that's a true story but that's uh that's
like one of the urban legends yeah
that's one of those Malcolm Gladwell
stories that just like becomes like
known by everybody whether it's real or
not
um have you heard the one about uh him
talking about David Goliath
yeah that one's great basically that
I'll summarize it in 10 seconds which is
basically like everyone talks about
David Goliath it's this Underdog versus
the big shot and they're like oh no it
turns out Goliath was like eight feet
tall because he had a pituitary gland
problem which means that he was like had
low IQ meaning he like was like you know
like an idiot and he was like big which
means if you have that pituitary
glandish or that issue you can't see and
at the time The Davids of the world were
like Shepherds and they had these slings
which is basically like they had a rifle
so basically uh this like lead BB that
this guy had it was already deadly and
he hit like a big guy who was stupid and
blind so it's really not that like
impressive
yeah David's a bully yeah
um all right so let me give you let me
give you an idea okay so I need a name
for this don't have a name uh it's a
working Title Here
but I think that isn't it crazy that
basically uh so we're we both invest in
startups now and um and I had this real
one of one of those startups that I
invested in is just doing absolutely
amazing and I'm like wow that thing is
gonna make like our little investment we
put 75k in I was like I think it's
currently probably at like four or five
million dollars it's a value that 75k
check and we're not like like it can
still run like that thing can still
double twice and you're not doing
anything
I'm not doing anything and I was like
and also so that's kind of a just
amazing and I'm like oh I'm excited like
the fund is gonna have like like the
first really really big winner because
we're only two or two years in and so
it's hard to know what's your what are
gonna be your big Winners but I think
that one's gonna be one of the really
big Winners now it's it's looking like
very very promising but the second part
is I would have never guessed that that
would be the one
um what can you say what it is
um no I don't want to say which one it
is yet
um
because I don't know if they want me to
say or whatever but basically I looked
back at literally that that the batch of
that quarter I did 10 deals and of those
10 I would have said like oh this is
probably like you know somewhere in the
middle uh I would not have guessed it's
like the one that's the big winner and I
thought wow that's crazy and I was like
you know it's pretty unfair that
employees at tech companies don't have
this sort of portfolio approach and it
got me thinking we talked about or the
founder of Sarah's list
or the founders we talked about Sarah's
list and how you know if you could pick
one of these companies that's gonna four
or five x over your four year period
there
um you know you can become a you know a
self-made millionaire without taking
huge entrepreneurial risks
but you got to pick right and so that
got me thinking like why do you have to
pick right and so I got two startup
related uh Community ideas for you the
first is by the way the way that you're
setting this up it's like you know
doesn't it suck that would you eat 4 000
calories a day you get fat why does it
have to be that way it doesn't like what
if ice cream I just had a bad rap yeah
what if I told you that if you exhale
while eating it has no effect at all
yeah okay the
um all right say my idea is basically
this you take a job at a tech company
you get your portfolio of stock options
or so you get your stock options you can
then click a button and you can what you
can pool it if you could pull it with
other companies that are like like
equally risk weighted so we basically
create like a um like a credit rating
agency where we kind of rate stock
options and we're like all right cool
like you're getting it at this price at
this valuation good we know that that's
that's set and secondly like there's a
community like uh desirability to these
options like maybe everybody in the
community really wants stripe options
because they're like wow stripe is great
but I'm not working on stripe right now
I'm working at the smaller startup that
I think has high upside but like I
consider stripe options to be AAA stock
options so you kind of get evaluation
and then a trust of the evaluation but
you basically put your you put your
stock in and you end up with let's call
it
40 your stock and sixty percent becomes
a blend of other stocks that you get to
either pick or index into out of the
startup community and so as a as an
engineer or as a designer or whoever you
are you're getting to be a part of you
get de-risked a little bit out of just
your one thing because maybe you got a
crazy CEO you got Adam Newman you
thought wework was a good idea now three
years later your stock options are
worthless they're underwater and like
you know that okay cool that's just how
the game works but does it have to be
that way is my question and so um Sam I
have two questions for you how good of
an idea on this on a scale of one to
incredible and secondly we need a name
for this idea
uh we already know I'm not funny on the
spot so the name thing I'm gonna that's
just I'm already gonna share yeah it's
already a swing and a mess I mean I
called my company the hustle like I'm
not even gonna be not on the spot uh so
I mean this podcast is called my first
million like we're not we're not exactly
good at this uh I told Sarah I want to
name my our kid buck and uh she she
wasn't feeling it
dude that's so funny I told my wife I've
been saying this since College I wanted
to name my Kid jumper
and then even I was like that's a
horrible name but at some point I was
committed because I had told like 12
people that I was doing this and those
are like my 12 friends and it made no
sense but I like had to stick with it
was like what are you what are you
saying this is not even close to what's
gonna happen yeah I've suggested Biff
and buff and uh
she's not into it I think these are like
you know in Batman comics where they
like punch and it's like pow it's like
Biff
first name Chuck middle name steak is
not gonna pass either but but TBD
so I'm not good at naming anything but
yeah I mean if you could pull this off
dude one thing that I learned when I was
running my company was I thought like oh
it's a privately held business I can do
whatever I want with the shares like I
could just you get a share you get a
share I can give this to you I didn't
realize that it's like it's not I guess
it's I don't know if it would
technically be considered regulated but
there's like rules right like you can't
for example if I give if I sell you a
share for a dollar I can't then six
months later and I'm like summarizing
this which means I'm probably a little
bit off I can't then go and give like
another employee that same share for 50
cents you know that's I I guess I I
don't know if that'd be considered
illegal or just against like certain
rules that where you can get in trouble
but it's like you can't do whatever you
want so yeah if you could but if you
could figure out how to like
operationally pull this off I think it's
badass
well there are like secondary markets
where you actually sell them but I think
this would have to be some you'd have to
create some some you know Financial
contract some some derivative product
that basically says
I pledge or assign my shares to this
portfolio basically and then in return
in exchange I receive shares of the
portfolio and there has to be some sort
of like consequence for trying to like
you know renege or whatever let's say
your startup hits it huge you're like oh
I don't want to do that so I don't know
the you know I'm gonna wave my hands in
the air right now that what I'm doing
right now is Legal Financial magic like
all right it's done that's done now and
now we just need to like you know start
the company and uh have it take off yeah
I mean by the way that's how I actually
run my businesses I'll go talk to the
lawyer or the account I'll be like I
don't know we don't have the uh we don't
we don't know what the contract says
like you know
you got it you got this give them Good
Vibes and I'm like hey I already agreed
to this deal you got to figure out how
that works like they're like what why
did you just talk to me first there's
like this leadership principle that
you're supposed to like give people
autonomy and like let them figure out
and Empower them and I always
you're empowered dude I'm empowering you
to figure this out you're welcome yes
your Ash has gotten powered my friend
congratulations yeah you're welcome
thank me later Daddy's show this makes
you happier yeah
yeah I mean if you could figure that out
I think I'm down I just empowered you
yeah I just empowered your ass
move on my part you like that
stuck on that Harvard so sorry speaking
of like investing I was uh reading about
the figma thing
so figma is like the design thing that
just sold for 20 billion so have you
heard of O'Reilly media
yeah they um they publish like books in
the conference right like yeah basically
what's the guy's name who started I had
dinner with him one time what's his
first name uh O'Reilly Tim O'Reilly so
he's like they call him like he had this
title like the Oracle of Silicon Valley
because he's been in the game since like
the 70s and 80s and uh originally
started writing books on programming and
his mission statement for his company
was actually really cool it was like uh
work on interesting stuff with
interesting people and he's like we'll
try books for a little while and then
he's like oh we'll just let's just stick
with books that's fine but like he
didn't actually necessarily care about
books he just wanted to like fund his
ability to work on cool stuff so he
anyway they're famous for writing these
books now they make like two or three
hundred million dollars a year uh with
the combination of books conferences and
uh like you can pay like 50 bucks a
month and like get access to like a
bunch of their like technical content so
it's content for engineers and [__] like
that anyway
they started a little fun using the
profits of their business and the
profits of their business were was big
but the fund wasn't necessarily big
compared to like a a full-time you know
proper fund fund and I was looking at
some of the stuff that they did and they
were in figma's seed round and I was
doing some math and this doesn't account
for dilution and if they sold early so
these numbers actually could potentially
be off by by a lot but assuming that
isn't the case uh if they if I don't
know what figma's figma's seed round was
but I think they raised three million
dollars so if you assume that it was
around a 15 million dollar cap uh it
sold for 20 billion that means it went
up by around 1300 times so a 250 000
check is something like 300 million
dollars and it's crazy that
this is one of those examples where the
main thing didn't even make the main
money you know what I mean like the or
sorry the main the not main thing made
more than the main thing
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
dude I mean there's so many examples of
that uh that actually leads me to
another topic I had but like
the remember that when we did Camp MFM
we stayed in a house and I don't know if
you saw it but did you see on the
stairway up to the guest bedroom those
plaques on the wall did you walk to that
staircase like the back staircase by the
chance yeah I thought they were just
like kids trophies like basketball clubs
I didn't even look at them
no they were adult trophies basically
what those were uh so the guy whose
house we were staying in he's a venture
capitalist oh and French capitalist who
lives in North Carolina and that on that
stairway up I was walking up there and I
was like
wait beyond meat and it's basically what
he was framing was a share certificate
it's like
um this guy uh you know whatever his
name was owns you know 45 000 shares
priced at 0.01 you know a dollar like
basically one cent a share and then it's
like Beyond me going public at 11 a
share and I was like wait I was just
like literally took out the calculator
app you know it doesn't go up to a
billion or whatever I was like unless
you turn like this is you got to turn
the phone oh really if you turn the
phone yeah that's a fun little fact wow
Game Changer I've been uh just like the
same I'm like what do you think
foreign
that's my goal not to be a billionaire
to get an e in my network yeah the
um the the but the guy basically had
like 20 of these on his wall and they
were just like yep issued shares at 22
cents a share now going public at 22
dollars a share and I'm like wow that's
like yeah these are crazy run-ups and
it's like okay you own 10 000 shares 20
000 shares one uh five thousand shares
fifty thousand shares and you just do
the math you're like this is a
staggering amount of money that's being
generated by this it is really
mind-boggling when you get these
Investments right and it is also really
funny how some of the really successful
people made their wealth not out of the
main thing that they did but in a way
out of the main thing that's it Tim
Ferriss is another example somebody was
asking me the other day they go how much
do you think Tim Ferriss makes a year
and I said I you know I don't know I
don't probably keep maximizes like no
what he can do like he doesn't sell out
you know fully like probably just five
to ten million bucks
yeah I said that's exactly I said five
to five to eight million dollars a year
probably of just like cash flow uh at
this point from you know podcasts
sponsorships newsletter or whatever
but uh book royalty something like that
those are maybe five million dollars a
year I said they're like oh okay that's
that's really good but uh you know I
guess that's not that big I go yeah but
like he also because he was Tim Ferriss
got to invest in Shopify and Uber and
like probably made hundreds of millions
of dollars off of his Uber investors
yeah over 100 million dollars my guess I
would bet that his net worth is north of
150 maybe north of 200 liquid
yeah which is I mean insane and
obviously like what that means is that
90 plus percent of it probably has come
from not his what if he described
herself you might say I'm an author I'm
a self-experimenter I'm a podcaster but
then all the money came from like you
know four Angel Investments or whatever
and um and I think that's really really
uh that's like really really impressive
but also more common than you'd think do
you know other people who had this
otherwise I have a example that I want
to go into anyways yeah just like a few
famous people just like you see like uh
like Nas the rapper like on all these
cap tables like yeah you you know the
guy who started figma in one of the
Articles it said that he had made 10
million dollars because he owned the
most expensive crypto one of those like
big ones uh and he bought it for nothing
and he sold it and he had 10 million
before he even sold figma but uh what
are the other ones
uh well I wanted to do I was thinking
about okay who do I do as Billy of the
week and so my Billy of the week that I
came up with was
Roger Federer the tennis player
[Applause]
[Music]
a million dollars isn't cool you know
what's cool a billion dollars
[Music]
so the US Open was on got me thinking
about tennis and
um and I saw that Roger Federer was one
of he's part of the uh the Billy athlete
Club so there's our Federer is
five athletes who have made a billion
dollars Tiger Woods
Floyd Mayweather
LeBron James
Ronaldo and I think Michael Jordan may
be messy so that might be six I think
it's five
um and now Federer is in that club so
give him like a 300 million dollar bump
though because he married Brooklyn
Decker
no that's not even included that's it
that's just bonus points uh so how does
this work so he has the same thing where
okay he's had a great career right
considered I think the goat in terms of
tennis tennis players so he's the
greatest tennis player of all time but
less than basically 90 of his money came
not from winning tennis tournaments so
he he's made 130-ish million dollars
from official prize money from
tournaments
um he's got 20 grand slam wins but most
of the money he makes is off the court
so just for example like is he retired
yeah so Roger Federer who just announced
literally yesterday that he's retiring
you know in his last year he paid like I
don't know 300 000 of prize money but 90
million from sponsorships off off the
course of the Court which is kind of
insane but his story is kind of cool
like and when I was studying these
different athletes I'm actually going to
do a whole episode that's just a deep
dive on each of these athletes the moves
that they made that made this happen
so one of Federer's big moves was that
early on he was not getting paid jack
[__] even when he was the best player
um they you know they would pay like
Andy Roddick more because they're like
oh Andy Roddick he's American America is
a bigger Market
Federer Swiss uh the Swiss market you
know that's the tiny population he's
kind of this like clean-cut sort of
boring guy he doesn't have this big
personality
um and even though he's really good he's
not as marketable he's not as sellable
and this is what they used to tell him
so he was getting like very small like
Nike was paying Andy Roddick more than
they were paying Roger Federer even
though by the way there was no break
number one that's the guy who married
Brooklyn Decker
oh yeah Eddie Roddick that's right damn
so uh so anyway so Federer goes and he's
like he's making so he's making like
very little money from Nike then he you
know he carries on and he goes and he
gets to a 10 million dollar uh a year
deal with Nike and it's sort of like
well you made it you know you should be
happy you got this 10 million a year
deal you know you're set your family's
set whatever
but he made two decisions which really
one decision led to two things that made
him an extra 600 million dollars and
here's what those two were so the first
is
his contract with Nike is coming up and
the expectation is that he's going to uh
just renew with Nike and he goes to Nike
he says hey this is now or then this
back then he's like I'm one of the you
know I'm one of the best uh tennis
players in the world like you know what
can he do for me and they're like Raj we
we put so much marketing behind you uh
you know the reality is you can't
compare yourself to basketball players
or to uh or to um soccer players like
you know tennis is just a different
thing here's the best we could do and
they gave him a deal and the deal was
basically like every year that you're
playing you get x amount of money and
he's and you know something similar to
what he was making right then
but he started he decides you know what
I'm gonna pause here I'm not just gonna
take this deal I'm gonna go shop around
a little bit more and see what I can do
and then Uniqlo comes at him with this
you crazy offer and so Uniqlo who's not
even in the like sports apparel game
really but they kind of had this like
tennis vibe that they're trying to come
they're trying to come to the west and
um and so Uniqua comes out of it they
offer him a 10-year deal worth 300
million dollars that that pays him even
when he retires so this 2018 he's
retired now
um I think he's retired now check that
he is retired now right guys
um but basically he uh he signs this
deal knowing that he will retire during
this deal and he's gonna get paid 30
million dollars a year uh doing this he
goes back to Nike he tells Nike hey guys
I got this offer can you also give me an
offer like this it doesn't even have to
be as much and they're like uh no we'll
throw in this like you know here's that
extra free t-shirt but you know yeah no
you're not getting a new deal give me a
part so he's like all right he leaves
but there's one key thing that he kind
of knew here which was that Uniqlo
doesn't make shoes and so he signs the
Uniqlo deal he starts wearing Uniqlo but
he's still wearing Nike shoes and they
ask him at the press conference or like
Roger I noticed you're still wearing
your Nikes like are you allowed to do
he's like oh yeah I don't have a deal
with them
um you know I'm shopping around let's
see what's out there for me uh you know
it's exciting I want to see see what's
out there and so for three years he
keeps wearing Nikes essentially for free
because he's just playing in them he
doesn't have a shoe deal and then
finally he gets he does a shoe deal with
the brand called on running which I'm
guessing you know about on the the
running brand there's another Swiss
company yeah they they they're kind of
taking the World by storm and you know
what's funny is they were one of our
advertisers when we first started and
they started spending a little bit of
money and they're spent kept going up
each year and I was like you guys are
killing it aren't you and they are I
think they make like over a billion in
Revenue now or maybe they even sold did
they sell no they went public so so they
went public at its peak it was like 11
billion valuation now with with Market
Corrections back closer to 6 billion uh
but at the you know at its peak so Roger
owned three percent of the brand in
exchange for he did an equity deal so he
said all right I get it you guys don't
have the same cash these guys can offer
how about a piece of the company and so
he owns three percent of the company at
its peak his steak is worth 300 million
dollars now so that's sort of like bet
on yourself and then do an equity deal
don't don't trade dollars for time you
know trade your brand for shares traded
for equity and that becomes for 300
million dollars and then he says all
right what else can I do so he then
takes matters into his own hands he cuts
ties with his current representation
company starts his own player management
firm to represent him and other players
then he starts creating his own
tournament so he's got his own like you
know cup that's basically like you know
the equivalent of the Ryder Cup in golf
where it's like Europe versus America uh
so he wants to do the same thing and so
now he's got his own competition thing
and so he's built this whole empire made
over a billion dollars total most of it
90 percent of of it off the court and I
think this is kind of amazing and if you
look at it there's a couple like like
interesting things here so
he um he goes up market so he goes
basically like how do I go premium so
his sponsors are Mercedes-Benz Rolex
lint chocolate he didn't do what Jordan
did which was Coca-Cola and McDonald's
right because he's like all right
where's my Niche where's my market how
do I get paid let me go to these like
you know go to Rolex basically
um the second thing that he did was he
um he uh he basically not only did he
bet on himself not only to take matters
into his own hands he played a very
patient game and so I think most people
would have been though during those
three years where they don't have a shoe
deal they'd just be counting the dollars
that they're missing out on I make 5
million or 10 million dollars a year if
I just sign this contract and this is a
common trait this is great LeBron James
story where LeBron is 18 years old he
graduates from high school that same day
you know the day the first day he's
legally allowed to
um Nike shows up a Nike or rebok I think
Reebok shows up at his uh
um at a school or whatever they take him
to a meeting he's like I remember dude
this is like the longest table I've ever
sat at like the longest boardroom table
he's sitting at one end I'm sitting at
the other end and he's like he slides a
check over to me and I look at it it's
more money than I've ever seen in my
life and LeBron comes from like single
mom she had him at 16 you know couldn't
pay electricity bills type of thing like
came from like he was dirt poor
and they basically offered him a 10
million dollar a year contract as an 18
year old kid he hasn't played a single
game in the NBA yet
he looks at it though he signed this now
and you can become our signature athlete
we will put this money behind you it's
the biggest deal we've ever offered to a
kid out of high school you know
congratulations son
and he doesn't have him he doesn't have
an agent he doesn't have anything at
this point
and he basically just says
you know
appreciate the offer man I appreciate it
thank you
um let me get back to you did I get back
to you this is 10 million dollars a year
what are you thinking and he's like and
he's like he tells a story later he's
like in my head I'm thinking man this is
more money than I've ever seen
but if Reebok's offering me this much I
wonder what Nike was offer I wonder what
these other like he's like I must be
worth something to these guys like I
don't have to take this deal yet and
just by being patient he ended up with a
much larger deal uh out of that just for
not like immediately grabbing so you
know what trait that's called it's
called um there's this awesome book by
this woman named Angela Duckworth called
grit have you ever heard that book Grit
I've seen like Silicon Valley people
talk about it yeah well it's like
centered around this story it's like a
study where they give a whole bunch of
kids uh they sit them down at a table
and they go hey look you can have one
marshmallow now or in a couple hours
I'll give you two but uh I'm gonna set
this here I'm gonna go out of the room
for a little while and handle some stuff
when I come back I'll see if you decided
to eat it or leave it there and that
will kind of tell me what decision you
made sound good and they leave and you
know they just see who does what and
they measure these kids for like 30 and
50 years like for years and years and
what they found is there's a correlation
between traditional financial success
you know like our traditional word of
success there was a correlation between
how successful they were and the
children that chose to not eat that one
in exchange for getting two in the
future and the ones who put it off you
know in eight two they were more
successful and what you've explained to
me is like the perfect like real world
but rare example of uh grit where it's
like no I'm willing to like not do this
thing now in exchange for a better
alternative and potentially in the
future
yes delayed gratification and that's
like the best way to describe that
I'm a marshmallow eater dude like say I
I would have been that first you know I
would have had it in my mouth while
they're explaining the instructions
there's another one coming
well I always got like frustrated when I
talked about like you know I told you
this when they talked about Warren
Buffett and Jeff Bezos talking about
patience and having fun I'm like dog
you're way too old go have fun now like
there is no there is no law there is no
long term man you're a long-term is like
Jeff Bezos now he's like you know he's
rushing you know you know Sig app over
there he's turning into a frat boy he's
like he's like he wants to be single do
roids you know drink beers on a boat and
it's like uh all right that's cool but
like not as cool when you're how old is
Jeff bezel that's good you're 57 as it
was when you were oh no man it looks
like it works it looked like it it looks
like it's working for him uh let me tell
you about this thing I read right before
we started so basically today I think
today they're gonna announce the FED
what they're uh rate raise is going to
be yeah we're gonna we're gonna learn
how much money we've lost today yes and
uh I don't know anything about that type
of stuff so I'm not gonna pretend I do
but I I read this interesting article
and it was about JP Morgan you know JP
Morgan's is like you know amazing bank
that's supposed to know what they're
talking about and I was reading about
what their predictions were and they had
this like day of scenario where they're
like here's like the three options uh or
here's the three possible outcomes and
you know they raise the rate by this
much this much and this much and here's
our prediction on what's going to happen
and they weren't like being funny they
weren't obviously they weren't being
funny they weren't trying to be like
silly or anything but I'm gonna tell you
the the range of the three options so
um option one well I'll just say like so
what's gonna happen is if they raise it
by 0.75 uh we are potentially gonna have
a five percent drop uh sorry if it's a
full percent full percentage Point
raised we're gonna have a five percent
drop in the market or if it's a point
seven five percent rate days we're gonna
have one of the best days on record for
the S P 500 so that's basically this
like the the most like one of the most
prestigious banks on Earth with
thousands of people studying this they
say it's either gonna be the best day
ever or a five percent drop which is not
quite the worst day ever but it's a
really bad day and it just goes to prove
that even the quote experts they don't
know [__] we're all just floating on
this rock trying to figure it out but I
saw this and I was like wait are you
kidding me is this a serious is this a
serious prediction it's gonna be one of
the best days ever or one of the worst
days ever or something in between that's
basically what the prediction is it
reminds me of those people where you're
like all right so you know what do you
think of the chances that happens like
it's a 50 50 man it's either gonna
happen or it's not gonna happen no like
just because there's only two options
doesn't make it a 50 50.
it's either going to be or it's not
going to be and then like tomorrow the
statement analyst is gonna be like well
you know I saw that going one of two
ways but I did not expect it going that
other way and the funny thing is it's
like they released like an 82-page
report and it just like I don't know man
at the end yeah yeah it just Trails off
yeah
NM not much you that's just what the
whole report should be because that's
basically what they just said like
what's your opinion not much yeah I
thought that was ridiculous that's
that's J so I was reading about all
these headphones that I'm like oh these
guys are smart but turns out like when I
was reading about these headphones these
guys are smart but they're like
kind of Lucky like they like just make a
bunch of games other hedged funds yeah
did this guy
um this is a hedged opinion by the way
this is the most edged opinion I've ever
seen in my life the
um it's like one time I was playing
roulette and I was uh so down on my luck
at the casino by the time I get to the
roulette table that means I have like I
got bored of Poker then I lost money in
five minutes playing Blackjack and then
I had like an absolute roller coaster at
the craps table and now roulette is my
like come down like my gambling addicts
out there will know what I'm talking
about and then at some point I'm like
just betting wrong every time like what
are the odds of me being wrong on red or
black 12 times in a row and then I'm
just betting both red and black just to
feel a little bit of a win and it's like
you know I'm just hoping a green doesn't
show up uh but basically like there's a
tweet that I saw that goes yeah I never
realized my whole net worth was
dependent on an interest rate like
until this year did you know what the
fomc committee oh did you did you know
that like your entire net worth was
dependent on 0.75 or one percent
interest rate hikes like who where the
[__] did this come from and why did it
turn out that they could no I remember I
could just ragged all my my net worth I
remember uh people talking about the fed
and I was like I don't know what the FED
is it's like it's like what people talk
about the FBI to be honest
that's a lot of like Breaking Bad and
narcos I have no idea like you know like
people say like well you know scientists
say or you know they say this that's who
I thought the feds was it was just they
you know there's he him her now there's
they you know I just thought it was the
pro the official pronouns are they and
fed yeah
dude I saw a guy on Twitter and he put
for his pronouns he put we Dash Damn
Dash boys dude that's it's the best one
it's the best one it's that guy Jack
um
read them boys that was his uh it's too
[__] good yeah that one always make
me laugh um all right I have something
interesting uh so in I found this video
on on YouTube If you Google on YouTube
like figma seed pitch so I watched that
this morning dude awesome let's talk
about it because basically the story is
I believe it was in this video was
filmed I think in 2013. so the video the
video was posted in 2020 but the way
looking at it he looks pretty young
maybe not 2013 young but he looks young
but regardless he's going through his
pitch and basically so figma recap sold
this week on Monday or Friday or
something like that for 20 billion
dollars one of the biggest exits ever
for uh Venture back startup uh and the
guy who ran it started the business when
he was 19. and there's this video on
YouTube of him pitching this guy named
Daniel gross who was actually on our pod
early on who had a fun and I had a few
takeaways from this pitch and so it's
like a 20 or 18 minute or 10 minute
video of him pitching my five takeaways
were a he's a kid even if it even the
video is like new he looks like he looks
like he's 18 but and he looks so young
and he talks kind of young but he's
really wise like you could you hear him
speaking and you're like it's very
impressive hearing him talk the second
is that the pitch was basically videos
of the product it was a prototype like a
demo of the Prototype not as much of a
deck and oftentimes throughout the pitch
it was pretty fun and he like used the
product to photoshop the the guy he was
pitching Daniel he photoshopped his face
and made it he made him look like
another person and Daniel the guy being
pictures like oh my God this is
hilarious this is awesome and Dylan the
guy pitching was just like having fun
and showing him the product and that was
so much better than just showing a deck
and the last two things were uh Tech
skills so the guy's like clearly
Technical and we often talk about how
like it does you don't need this stuff
and technically you don't need it
but God damn it helps this guy he's
clearly like they built something that
like was actually working and that's
such an advantage I do think you need to
learn that and the last thing is that
it's an MVP it does not look good at all
it's pretty ugly and it's and it's
mildly effective but it's effective
enough that you can see
the future
yeah exactly I watched this thing um so
you can find it if you go to YouTube it
says it's his name Dylan field pitches
seed stage figma to Daniel gross that's
the name of the the YouTube video it's
got uh what 30 000 views yeah I think
probably all of it's in the last two
days yeah yeah yeah
so he's pitching and my observation was
very much like yours first of all it
doesn't doesn't feel like a pitch
because uh most pitches are like
hey here's our company
um we're going after this really big
Market did you know we have a tam of you
know three trillion dollars a year or
spell spent on health care and they're
like oh wow okay
um three trillion dollars that's cool
what are you doing and they're like you
know uh you know we like we sell weed
yeah like we help you we help you do
squats with using your phone camera like
with better form it's like uh I don't
think that's the three trillion dollars
of Health Care spend but okay yeah like
I'm not sure and they always have like a
stupid quadrant thing with them in the
top right right everybody else you know
the the y-axis is if you're you know
stupid or smart and then this one is if
you're hard working or or lazy it's like
I don't know everybody else is lazy and
dumb and we're hard working and smart 20
billion dollar company are you sure
you're better than them
yeah yeah they're like you know poor
product it's like uh I don't know about
that
you're a poor product it makes me mad
I feel like very irritated what they
should do is put themselves in the
bottom left and be like but one day this
year
[Laughter]
six weeks ago when we met and then now
we've moved up and like just imagine the
trajectory like that's actually the
reality that's actually what's happening
we've already moved an inch on this
screen imagine a few of us five years
it's not the scale but
so so he's doing this pitch it's
basically literally the first slide it's
a picture of him on a boat
here's me
and I used to work at Flipboard toy he
goes I worked at Flipboard twice and
then he goes uh yeah this is my
co-founder he was my friend at school we
dropped out okay he goes then he shows
this video this talk he goes I was
really inspired by this talk by Brett
Victor inventing on principle by the way
this same talk I think is the one that
the webflow guy said was like his
inspiration for building webflow was the
same grainy ass video of this guy
explaining you know like how to build
like a like a real product well I think
that I think the takeaway from the talk
is or he says something to talk about
how uh it's morally right to help people
to create or something like that where
he's like your goal as a business
Builder is just help people create or
something like that and so the webflow
guy like the the demo he's doing in this
is like the difference between uh like
imagine you have to you have to choose a
bunch of options from a menu or write a
bunch of code and then push run and see
how it happens versus just you see the
thing and you can just edit it live like
drag and drop like it is so what you see
is what you get editor and how much more
creative you you can be when you're
doing it the what you see is what you
get version because you're just
shuffling things around in real time I
think everybody's kind of experienced
this in general
um so anyways he's talking he gives a
bunch of demos and all the demos are
like
kind of uh it's like oh look I you know
I made this like airplane look at Blends
in the background and then luckily I did
this thing like I merged these two
people's faces together it's like you
don't look at this and you don't think
ah 20 billion dollar company someday
like it's not like
you'd have to have a lot of foresight
really what you see when you see this is
like the only two indicators that this
would be successful is this guy seems
really smart and really like is a
creative Builder so like I'd bet on him
and to be successful in life for sure
and then the second thing was
and this is I think the underrated part
of what people talk about for figma
which is that there was a technology
change there was an inflection in
technology which was webgl had come out
and I remember when webgl first came out
I don't know
I mean but I'm not technologically
explain it but basically what it made
what it did was it lets you do cool
graphics stuff in the browser got it
that you weren't going to be able to do
unless you otherwise normally like
normally a browser was weak and if you
wanted to like play a game with cool
graphics you needed to like download the
game you need to have the application of
the game to run on your computer's
Hardware because doing it in the browser
was going to be too laggy too slow to
whatever and webgl was this like web
framework that let people build things
that were like they were like cool
graphic-y stuff 3D stuff like you know
Real Time stuff in the browser so that's
why when figma you would see people if
I'm working on the document with you I'd
see your mouse moving around in real
time and that was like a magic trick you
had never seen that before and at the
time I remember with like we were
building stuff and when webgl came out
all of our developers really intrigued
by it there was like cool stuff you
could do in webgl that you weren't other
like wasn't possible before and then the
question was now what's the application
and then where he landed was like I
think we can recreate the whole creative
Adobe Creative Suite in the browser and
here's how we're going to do it and like
that actually made a lot of sense he
didn't actually pitch it that well he
like mentioned those things during the
thing but like you'd have to like ignore
80 of what he said and just be like oh
that's just fun experimentation
this guy's smart webgl is a game
changing technology and this idea of
recreating the Adobe suite in a browser
making it free for everybody that's a
great idea and so like you had to sort
of see the the great pitch through the
forest here dude so the remember how I
told you about this guy named Brett
Adcock who's like this billionaire guy
who created uh a bunch of different
companies including basically a flying
car business remember that guy yeah so
he tweeted out the other day uh like
here's what I've learned about
entrepreneurship and one of the five
things that he said was
pick really really big Ideas because
then you could attract more investors
and it's easier to like uh get employees
and all that and all that type of thing
it's like that make no small plans thing
and that thing has always made me
self-conscious because like every plan I
make is like pretty small like like you
know I won't want marshmallow right now
not too later you know what I mean like
yeah I only make small plans compared to
like that plan and it's kind of cool
that like this figma thing
it doesn't seem that grand
it was but it doesn't seem that way
early on and that like makes me feel
better about my deficiencies so thank
you Dylan
you
mean when people say like Grand ideas
and I'm like
yeah but like writing a newsletter is
kind of fun right you know what I'm
saying like I don't know how to make
robots
[Laughter]
yeah but I do dream about that uh
sometimes I'm like okay me too and an
alternate life what am I doing right now
and I'm like why am I not you know
changing whatever you know building the
the next big thing you know the next
picks are making a flying you know car
or whatever it's like
I could do it I could I know that I
could do it and
um and I do think about doing it maybe I
will end up doing it but but it is for
some reason for me
I sort of am like uh
I don't know there's a how hard do I
want to work yeah uh questions
right like you know if I made my
quadrants I'm putting myself in the lazy
quadrant where I'm like I don't need to
do the hardest thing to impress myself
so I'm trying to figure out the things
that I can do that impress myself
um that are also like not gonna ruin my
life and my lifestyle dude well but what
I mean by that is just like I like being
home with my kids I like that I don't
have to like freak out I don't I don't
have like a office of a hundred
employees that are like we're hard
charging and we're about to die at all
times like I kind of like that I don't
do that
um so I just need to find a way to
impress myself that fits in my framework
and I think that what about right you
gotta do that like who's doing his [__]
you know Roger Federer I was gonna ask
you that like who's doing his stuff we
had Mark Laurie in the podcast and I
talked to a bunch of people who worked
with them and they're like yeah he's
really good at raising money and then he
hires people and then he just kind of
like they didn't it's exaggerating to
say he chills that's not true but like
there they kind of like said like well
he wasn't doing the hard work he did a
lot of the work early on but he kind of
like got all the leverage by getting the
money and having the idea and starting
it and then like everyone else he did a
really good job hiring them and letting
do their thing but same with Roger
Federer he ain't the one running that
running a lot of that stuff I wonder how
he partners with people yeah well the
other one that I was looking at was
Floyd Mayweather and Floyd Mayweather
has kind of an amazing uh bet on himself
story like this too like you probably
know it but I don't know if most people
know boxers in general UFC fighters make
basically nothing and uh with like you
know one or two exceptions and then
boxers kind of make more boxers can make
you know 10 million 20 million in a
fight and they can do that once or twice
a year that's great that seemed like the
top
and what Floyd Mayweather did was he was
like who the hell is making all this
money because I see that crowd is full
of people and the pay-per-view number is
huge but like where does the money go
and the reality was that the money would
go to the promoters it would go to the
cable companies it would go to all these
other people and so he decided to bet on
himself so he buys out his contract he
spent he takes 750 000 out of pocket and
buys himself out of top rank which was
the promoter that promoted Oscar De La
Hoya and Manny Pacquiao all these guys
and he starts you know Mayweather
promotions and now his business model is
like basically it's it's vertical
integration right like it's to use the
business school term he's like okay I'm
not just going to be the talent I'm also
going to be the production for the show
which means that I also collect the live
gate Revenue which means that I also
have to pay the other fighter like I
have to I have to write the check
um I'm also going to own a piece of the
pay-per-view I'm going to make it he's
like I'm gonna make money on every hot
dog sold in this venue I'm gonna make
money on the merch I'm gonna make money
everywhere and so because of that now
when he does a fight like his
um
Manny Pacquiao fight his Conor McGregor
fights he's pulling in somewhere between
250 and 400 million dollars that's crazy
himself on those five per fight so he
you know more than 10x more like 20x to
what he could make by betting on himself
and building that brand and then then he
created all the associated Brands so
then he basically created he's like why
am I these sponsors are paying me to
wear their [__] you know why don't I
just create you know The Money Team
clothing line and I'm gonna like own my
own clothing line rather than promoting
these other clothing lines LeBron did
the same thing he's like why am I
promoting McDonald's he bought equity in
Blaze Pizza and he's like cool I'll just
own a piece of this chain rather than
just be a sponsored athlete
um and so there's there's basically a
bunch a bunch of people do this model
and then Floyd you know he did he did a
couple things one was he went nuts on
the self branding so he changed his
brand from Pretty Boy Floyd
to Floyd Money Mayweather and he knew
that people were gonna hate that
he knew that people were gonna hate it
and he started doing hateable things
like he would just post a photo of
himself like at a dinner table but
there's no food on the table it's just
stacks of cash everywhere he's like this
is how I eat or whatever or you know he
would um you know just go throw like a
you know a wad of cash at somebody and
just like make fun of them because
they're poor and like they would pick up
the dollars because they're like well
this is like 10 grand and so like he
would do things that would get attention
he would do things at Village brand but
in reality he would look like this party
like this party guy he owns strip clubs
Never Smoke never drank you know like
the guy trains at like three in the
morning so you know he kind of built
this brand like he's this kind of like
badass or whatever but in reality he's
like a he like extremely well
conditioned athlete that was like
extremely disciplined and never like ran
into any of those problems but he hired
Al Haymon who Al had run you know he's
like he's like we have to do a whole
episode on on this because Al Haymon is
really intriguing Al Haymon if you
Google his face there's like four
pictures of him on the internet and he's
one of these guys I think he's like
famous for like you never meet him in
person but he does everything on the
phone and he's always in the background
of the most powerful boxers and fighters
in the world and before that you know
what he was doing no he was doing the
same thing in the music industry so he
represented Janet Jackson Whitney
Houston helped build their brands of
their their whole business Empires then
he taught Floyd how the music how
musicians make their money and he's like
oh I need to do that basically my fight
is me on tour I need to own the tour and
so I need to own the shows I need to
make the money from the tickets not just
be the fighter who goes on the stage and
so Al became his business guy on that
side and then he has Leonard Ellerbe who
does it on the on the Mayweather
promotion side and like the joke of
course about Floyd is that he can't read
and it's like he's like I can't read but
I I know numbers and like you know so
he's like you know he he know you know
he's found a way to make a ton of money
he understood like the core fundamentals
of a business
um and you had to put people in place
and so he generates a lot of money now
some people think he's going broke
because he spends so much I think he
might be like I totally believe that
that's hard to say dude I totally
believe that this podcast we
we are the internet dork Renaissance we
started with Adam Levine cheating on his
wife and then I think we went to like uh
the history of RSU option shares yeah
and then rsu's options chairs then we
talked about the FED at JP Morgan and
then back to Mayweather and Al Haymon
you can't get this anywhere else you
just can't they're gonna get all this
yeah yeah you know we are the Chinese
buffet of podcasts yeah they say that
like true wealth is created by being
like a narrow uh an inch uh uh an inch
wide but like a mile deep not here we
are we are we are a rain puddle we are
just going to cover everything just a
little bit
well you've built your whole life off
being four inches long so it all worked
out for you yeah
average at Best in lots of different if
you're average at best at just about
everything you're kind of above average
so it works out well
all right that's uh that's the show I'm
exhausted I gotta take a not nap after
that
[Music]